hello, how are you, greets sal and jaramillo
with your brief informative for today monday
may 3 a person is dead after
an accident this morning where the
driver fled happened to a
flamengo and expansion police say
a man was crossing  flamengo in
front of the springs hospital when he
was hit by a white mercedes
this street was closed for
several hours anyone with
information please contact the
authorities
several clinics are offering
the coronavirus vaccine around
the valley in which you do not need to
schedule a
The first appointment will be tomorrow at Church Las
Vegas' located near Sant
Ser and Sean Paul Browne. Another will be on Wednesday at the Bone Night Community Center near Warner Brothers and Chayanne. On
Thursday you will be able to attend the
Wind Recreation Center and near Power Huawei
and Tropicana.  finally on Friday the
hosting church will be offering
vaccinations for a full list  visit and
illusion dotcom diagonal in spanish
the cosmopolitan hotel is organizing a
job fair tomorrow from 10 to 2 in the afternoon
inside the show theater if you are looking to
fill several positions in different areas
for more information about this event and
other job fairs we have a list
complete on our
diagonal dot com edition page in spanish now
we move on to your weather forecast
expect a nice day with temps
in the 80s and a bit of breeze
temps will rise to the 90s
starting tuesday have a good day
i am this light  friend with his
informative brief for them neil in Spanish
[Music]